Marfa D my foe d put your tugs on me I
don't give a home I've written
about corporate corruption anything that
I'm passionate about or that strikes the
current prime minister of India
he is particularly known in India
because in 2002 in Gujarat there was a
mass massacre of much money was my way
of pushing back and saying you know what
you have these 10 things to tell me I
have one thing to tell you and that's
and one of my performances I had a group
of guys come up to me and grabbed my
hand and try and squeeze me and say this
is Modi's hand I've had you know slide
brushes but really it's it's it's
chickenshits I can't stop writing about
this issue that I can't stop laughing
was more download the aj+ mobile app and
join the conversation
available in your App Store now